je m'appelle Auggie Pullman
la semaine prochaine je commence la cinquième année et comme
je n'ai jamais été dans une vraie école auparavant
et à peu près totalement pétrifiée je
te verrai plus tard je ne veux pas marcher avec
tes parents parce que ce n'est pas cool mais
toi  je suis cool je sais que je le suis mais techniquement la
plupart des papas
aucun de ces casques tu n'as de
traitement tout ce que je sais je ne suis pas un
enfant tendre ordinaire j'ai eu 27
chirurgies ils m'ont dit de libérer tu vois
ici sans aide auditive  mais aucun d'
entre eux ne m'a fait passer pour des
clients d'incubateur ordinaires oh et ce
générateur tu sais ce qu'est une gomme à
effacer, regarde l'espace il y a tout ce
qui sera ma vie je ressemble à une souris
où je mets une capuche sur mon visage je sais que
tu ne le fais pas  je l'aime toujours mais je l'aime
deux fois sur l'espace tu n'es pas moche
Auggie tu dois dire pantalon si
tu es ma mère parce que je suis ta mère ça
compte le plus parce que je te connais le
plus haut tu n'as pas à le faire  fais ça je
ne sais pas de quoi tu parles d'
accord tu n'as pas à faire semblant d'être sur sa  y
tout jeu hé je suis vraiment désolé pourquoi êtes-
vous assis ici alors et quels sont les
retours pour un changement d'accord
qui est-ce que j'aspire à être c'est
la question que nous devrions nous poser
tout le temps
hé Jack configure et exact
je  aimer pouvoir contrôler la météo
qui n'était pas votre superpuissance qui est à l'
écran nul - o ce que vous faites est
visible vous êtes l'enfant le plus dur de l'
école
montrez-leur que vous ne pouvez pas vous fondre dans la masse quand vous
êtes né pour vous démarquer
[Musique]
puis nous avons pensé à la
chirurgie plastique, c'est après que la chirurgie plastique demande
beaucoup de travail à distance